you've seen people spinning balls on
fire or maybe it's LED lights on strings
maybe you've seen people roll a ball on
the end of a rope across their arm or
juggle of flexible prop through the air
and if you've seen somebody doing any of
these things I'm sure you've asked what
exactly is that it's called POI and it's
a movement art that has had a huge
impact on people all over the world and
I'd love to tell you more about it hi
there my name is Drex and if you're new
here I make videos about POI and more
broadly about flow Arts today I wanted
to take a moment to answer what might be
the simplest and most universal question
when it comes to this art what is it and
how do I talk about it without seeming
completely out of my depth hopefully
this video not only clears some things
up but also inspires more appreciation
the next time you encounter it or the
desire to explore it for yourself in
simplest form POI is a weighted solid
object attached to a flexible material
the weighted object is referred to as
the head the flexible material is
referred to as either the tether or
leash and the end of the tether is then
attached to a person's hand via a handle
a person using the POI will move the
head around using its connection to the
tether while holding the handle in a
variety of different ways the term POI
is both plural and singular and can
refer to a single prop of this design
multiple props at the same design or a
collection of props that may vary in
their specific details but I'll have
this fundamental design in common I
would refer to any or all these sets in
each case as my POI but a specific set
of two or more matching POI used
together are referred to as a set of poi
in the overwhelming majority of cases
people will use two POI at the same time
one held in each hand as I record this
it's also not uncommon for people to use
one three or even four POI at the same
time that are held in a variety of
different Fashions but using just two
POI one in each hand is considered the
standard though it's practiced by
hundreds of thousands of people all over
the world POI is still somewhat
underground as an art form most people
first encounter it via performers at
dance parties music festivals or street
performances and it has its origins in a
wide variety of different movement Arts
from all over the world some examples
include meals or Indian clubs a popular
dexterity and strength training exercise
using weighted clubs that reach the peak
of its popularity around the beginning
of the 20th century a contemporary form
of this Pursuit can be found in the
world of modern Club swinging and
juggling Bolas from Latin America this
art involves spinning metal balls on the
ends of very long strings to strike the
ground and intentionally create rhythmic
percussive sounds nunchucks from
Okinawan martial arts these are solid
rods made from wood plastic or metal
that are connected to each other via a
short flexible material like a rope or
chain glow stringing in which glow
sticks on the ends of strings are spun
rapidly around a performer and wrapped
around various parts of the body and
each other contact juggling in which a
spherical object is rolled across
different surfaces of the body and
balanced at particular points through
dexterity and practice but the word POI
itself is Polynesian and comes from an
art practiced by the Maori people of New
Zealand or aotearoa this art comes with
several variations depending on the
length of the prop from longer POI that
are performed similarly to Bolas and
meals to short POI that have a unique
style involving bouncing the POI all
around the body Maori POI is part of the
tradition of ceremonial dances
collectively known as kapahaka and is
frequently performed with large groups
of dancers moving in unison the version
of poi that I and many others across the
world perform is something of a Melting
Pot of all of these different influences
and many more because POI takes its name
from an indigenous art that is still
actively performed and practiced we try
to distinguish between the two in a
variety of different ways the Maori art
is sometimes referred to as Maori POI or
traditional POI and the version that I
perform is frequently called modern POI
can contemporary POI flopoi or more
broadly referred to as POI spinning this
comes from how we refer to the use of
poi in a contemporary sense people who
move around their POI are said to be
spinning them thus the people using them
are referred to as POI Spinners and the
art more broadly referred to as POI
spinning on occasion the activity of
moving with POI can also be referred to
as POI dancing especially if the artist
using the POI has a focus on integrating
movements in other parts of the body
with the spinning of the POI this is a
slightly less popular label for the art
than POI spinning but most POI Spinners
will still recognize it as describing
the same art just seen through a
slightly more specific lens and if you
couldn't guess it from the name the most
popular way that POI Spinners use POI is
to spin them specifically POI are
typically spun in such a fashion as to
trace out rounded geometric shapes in
midair many of these shapes closely
resemble a family of mathematical curves
called roulettes such as epitrocoids and
high hypertrophoids you might be
familiar with these curves as a result
of playing with a common toy that
produces them called a spirograph the
individual shapes and movements that POI
Spinners perform are referred to as
tricks or sometimes as moves a
choreographed series of poi tricks are
then frequently referred to as combos
patterns or sequences like in
skateboarding or skiing many POI
Spinners strive to learn as many tricks
as possible and there is a personal and
social cachet to learning more difficult
tricks that require many hours of
practice and training to achieve given
that weighted object on the end of a
flexible material is a pretty vague
definition it probably won't come as
much of a surprise that there are a wide
variety of common ways that POI are
constructed and that some of these form
factors can result in some very specific
stylistic flourishes we tend to talk
about there being a clear division
between lit POI that released light in
various ways and often are specifically
geared towards performance situations
and unlit POI that are used for practice
as well as occasional performances but
really can only be seen in well-lit
situations unlit POI are also known as
practice or daytime POI and come in the
broadest range of form factors and
unique Styles sock POI are commonly a
DIY first set of poi that are made by
dropping weighted objects inside of an
old pair of socks and spinning them
while holding on to the opposite ends
more recently it's become common to
create POI that looks similar to Sock
POI using less flexible fabric to create
a more professional looking and
eye-catching product some sets of unlit
poi will feature a section of light
fabric attached to the head that has a
similar function to the ribbons and
ribbon dancing depending on the width of
the fabric these can be referred to as
ribbon POI Veil POI or in cases where
the fabric takes up most of the length
of the tether flag POI but perhaps the
most common type of unlit poi currently
are what are called Contact POI
generally constructed by drilling a hole
through a stage or contact juggling ball
and threading a rope in with a handle
through it contact POI are a popular
option for most styles of poi and also
offer artists using them the unique
stylistic option of being able to roll
the heads across different surfaces of
the body in a manner similar to contact
juggling again this is not a
comprehensive list of all types of unlit
poi but they're the most common options
you're likely to find and as for lit POI
they come in two different varieties LED
POI and fire POI LED POI Place
electronic components including a
battery lights and circuitry within the
heads of the POI they're designed to be
used in more dimly lit situations like
dance parties and Raves many form
factors for Led POI mirror the form
factors available for unlit POI but pack
electronic components inside of a
variety of translucent materials for
example there are multiple options
available for Led contact POI and led
sock POI but there are also form factors
more unique to LED POI as well there's a
large amount of overlap between the glow
stringing and poised spinning
communities with the two Arts being more
or less interchangeable in many contexts
because of this rod-shaped form factors
for Led POI are quite popular among
artists who would describe themselves as
practicing either or both arts and some
higher end LED POI include strips of
multiple LEDs with complex circuitry
enabling them to display patterns thanks
to the Persistence of vision effect some
have a variety of patterns built in
While others can have patterns and
images uploaded to their memory via a
computer program or smartphone app these
sets of LED POI called programmable POI
are considered the standard for many
professional POI performers all over the
world but of all the types of poi fire
POI are perhaps the most eye-catching
and the style that first attracts many
people to the art fire POI can be
considered to be more broadly a part of
the genres of fire spinning fire dancing
fire performance or the fire arts and
the act of using fire POI referred to as
spinning fire for much of the 2000s many
if not most people who spun POI unlit
considered it practice for spinning with
fire and fire spinning itself was
treated as the true focus of the art and
the highest expression of it this
changed considerably during the 2010s
and into the present day such that while
fire spending is still respected it's no
longer considered to be the focal point
of the arch spinning unlit poi has
become popular enough that now fire POI
is considered a sub-genre of the broader
art of poi spinning rather than unlit
POI being seen simply as a lesser form
of practice to get to spinning fire and
as for the fire POI themselves fire POI
heads are made from heat resistant
absorbent materials like Kevlar which is
usually knotted up to increased volume
and surface area this material is
usually referred to as a wick or wicking
and is connected to a tether made out of
another heat resistant material like the
aramid Rope technora or a metal chain to
the handle the heads themselves are
dipped in a liquid fuel such as white
gas kerosene lamp oil or paraffin
they're lit on fire and the perform
farmer will have a few short minutes to
perform with them before the fuel is
exhausted and the fire goes out special
cases of fire POI include snakes a type
of poi in which the wick is made extra
long so there is no real difference
between the tether and the head snakes
produce very bright sheets of fire
around the performer there are also a
variety of types of fire POI that
produce Trails of Sparks and massive
displays of light sometimes this effect
is produced by attaching an incendiary
device like a Roman Candle to the end of
a tether another option is to use what
are called cages metal enclosures that
hold on to stores of wood chips or steel
wool when either material is lit up it
will rapidly burn down to small Embers
that will pass through the bars of the
cages producing a trail of Sparks behind
the POI head and one quick note fire POI
in any form is dangerous and should only
be performed by somebody who is properly
trained and in the presence of a safety
spotter if you're interested in learning
these skills I will include a link to
some videos I've done on fire spinning
safety down in the description POI
spinning as an art form has matured to
the point that there are now a multitude
of different approaches genres and
unique Styles within it I've already
done a video exploring what I consider
to be the different contemporary schools
of poi spinning that I'll link to in the
description but before I wrap up I want
to highlight a few specific terms that
pop up frequently in the POI world with
regard to style and expression to be
aware of the first of those terms is the
word flow this word comes from the work
of Hungarian American researcher mihel
chikset mihel who identified it as a
unique psychological State associated
with being in the zone that carried with
it feelings of focus fulfillment and
creative breakthroughs in the context of
poi spinning flow is used both to
describe the Elegance with which a
performer can work with music transition
between tricks and quality of movement
as well as to describe the state of mind
that many performers hope to enter when
spinning their POI the emphasis on Flow
and more specifically on entering a flow
state has come with the Advent of
codifying other props like POI that are
used as skill toys with a meditative
aspect into the umbrella term flow Arts
the popularity of this term to describe
these movement Arts has risen
dramatically in the past decade and a
half and it's found its way into common
usage in a variety of different Fashions
flow is now frequently used as a synonym
for the art of spinning poi for any
given period many POI Spinners will say
I'm going to go flow for an hour as a
way of saying that they're going to go
practice or free Spin it's also not
unusual for POI Spinners to complement
each other by saying that they've
enjoyed each other's flow as a way to
say that they've appreciated watching
them spin or that individual artists are
trying to find their Flow by attempting
to deliberately enter a meditative State
as they spin and the intense look of
concentration people get when trying to
practice a new trick or skill this is
often jokingly referred to as flow face
as the popularity of flow as a concept
grew the point Community also saw the
definition of a concept that was
frequently seen in opposition to it
namely Tech or Tech POI while the
origins of the term are a little bit
hazy it's frequently thought to be a
reference to technique or to the
technical nature of very difficult POI
tricks Tech POI enthusiasts Focus their
practice on tricks that require
virtuosic precision and the capacity to
explore POI in a mathematic or
systematic way it's not unusual for Tech
POI enthusiasts to create
classifications for POI tricks that have
similar elements in common and use what
they learn from those tricks to create
other new tricks with those elements
still in common exploring these options
is frequently referred to as doing
research and the specific school of
thought grouping these tricks together
as being a framework or a theory Tech
POI enthusiasts also stereotypically
Place more emphasis on the movement of
their POI than they do on the movement
of their bodies resulting in an
immediately identifiable posture with
rigid locked legs a shoulder's width
apart that is sometimes pejoratively
referred to as a tech tree and finally
the past decade has seen an explosive
growth in POI themselves being used as
props for toss juggling people who
utilize POI for this fashion are as
likely to be referred to as POI jugglers
as they are POI Spinners and some
performers will have very passionate
opinions on which if either term is
appropriate for the art that they
practice now there are a huge variety of
other terms associated with specific POI
tricks framers for understanding them
and philosophies towards the art and if
I were to try and explain all of them
here then this video would be hours long
I just wanted to give a quick overview
for people curious about the art to
begin to explore it and get a grasp on
some of the most common terms in it want
to see me do a deep dive into explaining
the terms around flowers body tracers
Caps or any number of other specific
sets of poi tricks and Frameworks leave
me a comment and I'll do a follow-up so
whether you send them a roll them
whether you burn them wrap them toss
them or tangle them POI are amazing and
I really hope this gave you some
appreciation for the breath of the ways
in which they're used some idea of the
important terms that get thrown around
in this world and some inspiration to
learn more about them yourself speaking
of which if you'd like to learn how to
spin POI I have a tutorial series that
takes you through all the basics that
I'll link to down in the description as
well as up in the cards if you're
watching this video on YouTube and if
you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it and to help my channel grow I also
just wanted to take a moment to thank
the friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flowfests flow toys
juggling calling pyro Terra light toys
spinballs and Ultra POI for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
just like yourself by checking out the
links that I have down in the
description of this video and and
special thanks to the non-business
Friends of the channel That is Lane
machinsky and Becca beckaden thank you
both so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission
[Music]
foreign
would not be possible without the
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
they along with the people listed down
in the description helps make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching think that videos like
this are awesome then please consider
signing up to support them I have a
patreon over at patreon.com
drexfactorpoi if you sign up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be making it possible for me
to make more videos like this one and
share the love of poi spinning and flow
Arts with the whole wide world so please
go give that a look thanks in advance
want to learn more about the broader
flow Arts I have a whole series I did on
the flow Arts as a concept and different
topics within it that I'll link to down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
the YouTube algorithm also thinks that
you might like this top video given that
it's been popular with other are people
who watch videos on my channel so please
check that out if you'd like to see more
in the meantime thanks for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace